nearly 25 percent of all nevadans have
gotten at least one dose of the covid
vaccine
however many are still hesitant to get
the shot a new campaign has started here
in the valley to increase vaccine
awareness in our minority communities
clark county partnered with grassroots
groups and community organizers with
billboard and
social media the message is simple get
your shot when you're eligible
the more immunity we can create the more
lies we can save and the faster we can
open up our economy
save our small businesses and get people
back to work
african-americans make up about 12
percent of clark county's population
however
only 6 percent have gotten a dose of the
vaccine
advocates say misinformation and a
distrust of the government is feeding
the vaccine hesitancy right now vaccines
are open to anyone in nevada 65 and
older
anybody 16 and older with an underlying
health condition
frontline medical workers teachers and
hospitality staff
if you need help making or canceling a
coronavirus vaccine appointment you can
call the number on your screen
1-800-401-0946 the number is available
from 8 until 8
7 days a week and we have all the
vaccine information you need
at 8newsnow.com